and brian that is why masks are back or
at least they will be as of 12
01 a.m friday morning this after the cdc
issued those new recommendations for
areas with levels of high transmission
like clark county
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
is live near d-i-n eastern
and sally i understand that you spoke to
some restaurant owners i'm sure there's
some mixed feelings about this new mass
mandate
that is correct denise while some people
are for it others are against it some
people
are feeling extremely frustrated others
are scared and overwhelmed restaurants
such as lindo michoacan say they are
preparing
for this friday basically the risk of
getting
the virus is greater now than it has
ever been before
tonight the southern nevada health
district warning we're seeing more
coveted infections in both vaccinated
and unvaccinated people
and that's renewing the call for people
to wear masks yvonne wallace co-owns two
restaurants and says their staff has
continued to wear masks
because of so many visitors a lot of
visitors from
not just from our surrounding states but
all over the country
wallace says while it's not a big change
to them they have noticed a lull in
business through this latest swing in
numbers
people are starting to get concerned
again
as the numbers rise i think a big thing
for us as small business owners is
taking care of our staff and our
customers
so we with our frustration we just know
that we have to do whatever's right for
them
lindo michoacan owner javier barajas
agrees with the mass guidelines while
wallace hopes
everyone understands we're going to do
everything we can
to that it's in our hands to implement
the policy
the hard thing is is the general public
is not being nice to customer service
wallace and barajas remind the community
that their business license and
employees mean the world to them
and hope people choose to be kind please
don't get mad if we ask them to wear the
mask
the southern nevada health district says
it's hard to say when the recommendation
will end right now 50 percent of our
population still needs to get vaccinated
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now